Alien: Covenant hits theaters on May 19, and
fans couldn't be more psyched. Formerly known
as Prometheus 2 and Alien: Paradise Lost,
this latest installment in the Alien saga
continues the story set in motion by 2012's
divisive Prometheus. Here's why we think this
sci-fi horror flick is going to be a return
to form for the Alien franchise — and a
big step forward from the last movie.
Xenomorphs
While it may or may not be a traditional Alien
movie, Alien: Covenant has at least one thing
that Prometheus didn't — xenomorphs.
Yeah. Those guys.
Like the poster for Alien: Covenant that was
revealed in March 2017, this trailer is crawling
with aliens. We've seen a facehugger spring
from an egg, a new backburster Neomorph, and
multiple shots of xenomorphs in familiar confines
like spaceship hallways and creepy caves.
There's even a stare-down between a xenomorph
and Danny McBride, with nothing but a spaceship
windshield between them. What could that alien
want? Hopefully this:
H.R. Giger is all over it
Visual artist H. R. Giger is gone now, but
as long as the Alien franchise exists, his
ghost will haunt it. The guy was into some
spooky occult stuff. You don't make a book
like the Necronomicon and then peaceably surrender
to death's cold embrace. You stick around
and haunt stuff, starting with your very own
museum in Switzerland, and continue with a
whole bunch of Hollywood blockbusters.
But back when Alien: Covenant was still Prometheus
2, director Ridley Scott seemed intent on
going in a new direction, stating publicly
that the film wouldn't feature any xenomorphs
at all:
"The beast is done. Cooked." Of course, we
know that's not the case anymore. It's unclear
what prompted the subsequent about-face, but
maybe Scott realized that Giger's influence
on Prometheus was actually its saving grace.
Say what you want about the directing, writing,
acting, and characters — that movie is at
least visually dazzling.
Giger's Alien aesthetic — featuring things
like slime, biomechanics, a metallic black
and blue palette, and skeletal hinges — is
an intrinsic part of the franchise. And from
the looks of things, Scott and his team have
realized it. Alien: Covenant represents a
step in the right direction with regards to
honoring Giger's legacy and keeping his ghost
happy.
Bringing back body horror
As important as Giger's concept art and designs
have always been, the xenomorph also owes
just as much to screenwriter Dan O'Bannon's
original script. The alien's anatomical anomalies
inspire real dread in the first Alien movie
— and that's by design. As O'Bannon said
in a 2002 retrospective, "[With Alien,] I'm
going to attack the audience."
Like other great "body horror" movies, Alien
exploits moviegoers' fears of being physically
violated by using grotesque imagery and gore.
Alien: Covenant's trailers and other promo
materials make prominent use of the series'
strongest quality — its clever use of "body
horror" tropes.
"My body is ready."
The new crew
Did you ever wonder why a group of scientists
would remove their helmets on an alien planet
just because the air appeared to be breathable?
You're not alone. As Forbes' review put it,
the characters in Prometheus "do ridiculously
dumb things. When they see black alien ooze,
they touch it. When they find a giant severed
alien head, they bring it on the ship and
perform inexplicable experiments on it."
They're supposed to be scientists, yet they
behave like idiots, so it's hard to care when
they die.
That said, Alien's crew had its fair share
of bad decision-making, but it was always
grounded in the crew's mutual experience of
working for a big corporation that treated
them as expendable. The bond they shared with
each other was both professional and personal.
The Nostromo's fate was horrific because audiences
actually cared about the crew.
By all appearances, Alien: Covenant seems
to correct one of Prometheus's biggest missteps
— the aloofness of its crew of scientists
and specialists, which made them hard to sympathize
with. In the "Prologue: Last Supper" clip,
the new crew lets loose and throws a party
to celebrate being the first colonists on
a mysterious planet. Recasting the main characters
as colonists aligns it more closely with Scott's
original film, and that's a good sign.
Music to your ears
Composers Jerry Goldsmith and Lionel Newman's
incredibly tense score set Alien apart from
other horror movies. And if Alien: Covenant
seeks to recapture the feel of the first movie,
it'll need a comparable score. Fortunately,
there's a good bet that Jed Kurzel is up to
the task. You might already know him as the
lead singer of the band the Mess Hall. He
knows how to create tension, and he's amassed
a serious résumé: he scored his brother
Justin Kurzel's 2011 psychological horror
film Snowtown. Plus, say what you will about
the rest of Assassin's Creed, but Kurzel's
epic score was undeniably solid. As the trailers
for Alien: Covenant show, Kurzel lets the
onscreen action influence the music, allowing
for low ambient tones in dark tense sequences,
stretches of silence during conversations,
and sweeping anthemic accompaniment for the
action-horror set pieces.
Practical effects
Ridley Scott is known for having a healthy
distrust of CGI effects. What does that mean
for Alien: Covenant? More of the classic creature-feature
practical effects that made the first two
films in the series so frightening. To horror
fans who can't help but laugh at CGI monsters,
this is welcome news.
Ridley Scott knows what he's doing
We're confident that Ridley Scott will do
right by fans of Alien — and fans of Prometheus.
There's a lot riding on Alien: Covenant. If
it hits the sweet spot in terms of box office
grosses, Scott's promised as many as a half
dozen more Alien movies.
As James Cameron put it, even "not-so-great"
Ridley Scott films are worth seeing "because
he is such an artist.” Put simply: Even
a mediocre Ridley Scott movie is still at
least intermittently compelling, and we don't
expect that to change anytime soon. Let's
keep our fingers crossed that Covenant is
the return to form we're all hoping for.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love too!